that's early in August of 1995 I've just
turned 32 I was the proprietor of the
Katmandu Riding Academy shell was my
wife of 16 years I thought I was blessed
I had the world at my feet and I had I
had a life that most people don't have
we're staying at a place called a zebra
in there's nothing that was unusual with
the trip everything seemed normal
so we got to know we're going to stay
with our luggage in we put my daughter
to sleep and we had a little bit of a
chat round down from the flight and went
to bed
we only been in bed for about no more
than an hour the door was kicked in
without any warning that there's guys
from the bursting through that's what
these guys are coming in to rob us this
thought was to defend himself defend my
wife and defend my daughter and have
pushed me against the wall and then the
pointing guns at me please and we've
come to arrest you
they took me in to talk with captain
Sanergy and I was a hundred percent
confident I would be released and I
would be applying going home beating out
of that flag now that helped and leaving
this nightmare behind he said this is
your houses we found it now you are
going to be charged there's a number of
ways we can get out of this you can give
me your travel sticks you can give me
your watch and we can make this a very
small problem
oh oh we can make it a big problem and I
said you want me to find how the
Travelers Cheques to you so I can evade
prosecution charges something that I
haven't done I mean it's not this is not
mine this is not right
in hindsight if I'd known that I would
have lost theirs my family lose so much
more I've given everything I had without
any qualms have no idea that the whole
world was going to be turned upside down
it was corruption I knew I was being set
up I did not touch these drugs I did not
have anything to do with these drunk
there was always I mean one thought
escape escape escape Milan in Indonesian
means that adversity unlucky misfortune
so going into a prison that has a bad
name to start with I wasn't expecting
roses the assassins of Marcos I had a
really formidable reputation because
they were quick to kill
the thing within the prison is if
someone says I'm going to kill you you
don't worry about it it's the one who
doesn't tell you is let me kill you
we'll come get you and that's what the
assassins were known for they never
warned you face went out who killed you
there's about six o'clock in the morning
I woke up tomorrow so and on top of me I
could see the knife in muddy so his hand
he's got the knife up and they're ready
to shut down and he looked at my chest
and then at my eyes and then he was
bringing it down I knew I had to get
myself away from the death strike the
knife then went into my chest it went
down right through my lung and sunk into
the hilt it's like somebody punching me
really hard in the chest I've reached up
now got my hand into his face
and he started to scream and pull back
and as he's pulled back he's pulled me
up on my feet and I was on my feet and I
thought yeah I gotta change I'm on my
feet I'll just ran out of steam I
dropped to my knees and they I realize I
can't breathe properly and I just
blacked out